[Music]  according to discovery channels last  week shark week got the highest ratings  in the show's history highest they've  ever had yeah  now this despite a lot of criticism from  scientists and shark fans who say the  channel used fake footage  in their science documentaries that's  been kind of a scandal  now folks if they used fake footage i  couldn't tell i watched all of shark  week i didn't notice it but let's roll  some of it again see if you can tell  sharks seem to possess an evil  intelligence this white tip reef shark  draws out the misery of his next meal by  toying with it until he gets bored and  ends the game  off the coast of matamoros sharks drive  this school of stripers toward the reef  in the ocean  speed is life  and the slow  meet a savage end  in south chile the penguins off the  magdalena island find safety on land but  their food is in the ocean and so are  their enemies  [Applause]  [Music]  that's legit